[Aplausos]
algunos de ustedes ha sentido alguna vez
el vacío existencial que tratamos de
llenar desesperadamente
muchas veces de inventarnos es una lucha
interminable que tenemos como seres
humanos contra sí mismos
y sabe por qué porque este vacío
existencial pilla gritos
para por encima de nosotros mismos de
los principios de nuestros valores
contables de pertenecer a sentirnos
amados
o sea menos preguntas
se aplica cuando dura este camino
el producto alcanza el remordimiento la
culpa del arrepentimiento de colocar la
tarjeta 15 prácticamente eso
y el rigor de clases
hacer las mismas
la verdad es que sí
este es el libro además porque quiero
explicarles un poco
que la resolución de todo esto mismo
pero la familia determinante en la idea
los primeros siete años son los más
importantes para forjar esta idea de
quién eres
hay en tus miedos inseguridades y de
acuerdo está determinante basar actuar
el resto de tu vida a grandes rasgos hay
esta teoría que me parece interesante
que es la teoría de la vida de abandono
está voy hablando no es un poco para
cinco el vacío existencial que les estoy
tratando de explicar
y lo importante aquí es que era con esta
teoría todo lo hacemos con esta huella y
necesitamos satisfacerla comiendo 7
necesidades básicas amor placer
comprensión conocimiento del
conocimiento en fin pero la cosa es cómo
le hacemos en primera instancia dice
esta teoría supone que tan tarde la
madre está primera figura importantísima
con la que obtenemos estas necesidades
después con la familia coincidiendo un
poco conforme después poder en sus
amigos no tiene aquí no se acuerda de
100 mil estupideces que no es capaz de
hacer contar de pertenecer a este grupo
de amigos después la parezca cada el
amor parece que le achacamos todas estas
responsabilidades de hacerlos sentir
plenas me dices reconocidas armadas
inspiradas 50 en cuanta cosa más que
contar 12 debiendo así nos vamos con los
hijos y con quienes tener de 1 en los
rising parados
es difícil parada porque realmente
sentir el rigor de este vacío es
horrible es horrible y tenemos la idea
de que logrando estar o ser
siendo parte de equis situación que para
nosotros representa lo que queremos ser
vamos a hacer 20 es por siempre y
luchamos toda la vida para hacer eso
y resulta que me sigo sintiendo incómoda
sola vacía este en fin que si nos vamos
yo en algún momento en mi vida me
percaté de que tenía cierto
reconocimiento allá afuera
no tenía el suficiente en mi casa porque
acuérdense que somos insaciables según
yo quiero pensarlo a la jungla que en la
pubertad digo a los pregón sobre todo a
los hombres la neta como yo me sentía
bien reconocida y me sentía muy bien y
un día uno de estos hombres que parecía
el hombre perfecto guapo el partido
perfecto dijo que no se medían bien los
jeans blancos
si los jeans likes no me volví a poner
los jeans blancos
en años
así como lo oyen ha sido ridículo y
absurdo como suena no le volvió a poner
dispuesto a jugarme ese nivel de
reconocimiento que obtener allá afuera
por nada
sufrir muchísimo la verdadera y imaginas
estar a merced de toda esta jungla que
le llamo yo
para determinar si me siento bien o mal
triste amada reconocida
[Aplausos]
ahora tenemos la perfecta cereza en el
pastel que son las redes sociales
cuando te puedes explayar en todo lo
ancho al exponer esta vida ideal que no
existe a jugar con tu yo ideal
a que el número de likes y de seguidores
te hagan sentir mejor o peor es neta
ya tenemos 100 100 mil porque ya no es
nada quién eres sino si tienes 100 100
mil y nos vamos por más
ya estamos rompiendo nos la cara por ser
perfectos y actuar a imagen y semejanza
de quien creen
pues de todo el mundo porque según los
de los otros lo mejor es estar de
acuerdo con labor de ghana
[Aplausos]
y todo esto
pues sí a mí me llevo un momento como de
crisis yo tenía claro que yo siempre
sentí un impulso por ayudar a los demás
y bueno no entiendo un poco porque yo
crecí con dos padres que me comentaron
esto toda la vida mi madre un poco con
niños está siendo mediado desde que
llega una niña mi padre un poco más con
la gente en el campo y es el otro y será
pues algo que yo disfrutaba hacer
después no tenemos consciente porque lo
disfrutaba pero me fui a estudiar
psicología digitación serlo en formas y
voy a ayudar a ayudar forma estudié
psicología luego la maestría en
psicología y estando en el consultorio
con pacientes de verdad lo saben cómo me
proyectaba yo no sólo entendía un poco
más en el teatro el comportamiento del
ser humano sin el sufrimiento este
círculo vicioso del que les estoy
hablando
tener ganas de gritarle al mundo un poco
como estábamos atorados en esto y de
poder aprovechar el conocimiento que
tenía un poco de acá fuera más las
herramientas que han adquirido de la
psicología más que yo me proyectaba
porque lo he vivido toda mi vida y me
puse a hablar ya escribir en revistas en
televisión en mi blog en mis redes
sociales por supuesto que para mí es
nuevamente importantísima de trabajo
pero pues hay que aprovecharlas
adecuadamente y lo hice y cada vez que
tengo la oportunidad de alivian darle a
alguien más el dolor existencial y el
vacío y desamparo pues lo hago aquí
estoy otra vez compartiendo esto con
ustedes a ver si alguno de ustedes le
puede ayudar esto que les digo
y
pues llegué a la conclusión de que como
me cayó el 20 del porqué de que esta fue
la primera vez que probé las mieles de
una satisfacción real
y puede llenar este vacío existencial
que hago así porque lo siento aquí
habría que ver los docentes tú
platicando con los personas y me dicen
que aquí que quien sabe pero esa fue la
primera vez que sentí esa esa
posibilidad
él les decía que es difícil parar porque
pues pasamos por encima de nosotros
mismos todos los días los ponemos en
manos de alguien más con tal
de sentirnos bien y determina nosotros
íbamos estar bien o mal hoy mañana
esto lo único que hace dios no sé qué es
más difícil además o sea mantener este
ritmo de tratar de ser y estar y
pertenecer y así que más me dinero en el
canción y energía está negando día de ti
mismo o para atreverte a hacer tú porque
la resolución de esto está en atreverte
a ser tú
pero cómo empezar por dónde empiezo toda
la vida ha sido a partir del otro y así
como lo empiezo a sentirme que tengo
todas estas cosas de mí el amor el
reconocido en sí sí me cag otorgar y si
sé que tengo ciertos beneficios que la
vida me ha dado pero no sé por dónde
empezar y es que como vamos a saber
si no somos
no se dan cuenta como estamos atrapados
toda la vida hemos hecho pequeños
sacrificios
que nos han ido enterrando
cada vez más nosotros mismos llegando
los evadiendo los y sin querer
escucharlos de pronto tienes un gusto
por ahí que no te atreves a compartir
porque sientes que nadie nada más todo
está aquí de que sientes que no nos le
va a gustar esto no hemos tendido hacia
el fútbol digamos y sacrifica ese
gustito prefieres te sientes más a gusto
crees que así viviendo así como robot en
modo supervivencia estás en tu confort
son
yo los invito a que lo piensen nuestro
punto que de costo tiene eso
estamos en la total incomodidad en la
instancia habilidad atrapados
podría quedarme aquí platicando horas
pero lo que creo que puedo compartirles
son algunas de las cosas que me han
ayudado a mí a dejar de luchar porque si
les puedo decir una cosa
con esto que hacemos nos aleja de
nosotros mismos de tal manera que no nos
demos la oportunidad de escucharlos de
ver que nos hacen naturalmente que se
nos a quienes somos de ser los
auténticos que siempre hemos querido ser
quien no quiere ser auténtico
y no nos hemos dado cuenta que la mejor
opción eres tú cuando estás en esta
posición de a tener que hacer tú no hay
más ni menos ni mejor ni peor porque tú
eres único no hay nadie como tú
esa es la mejor forma de ser auténtico
con nuestros padrones esos zapatos en
esa comodidad que recobra su paz
interior
proyecta su la pasión la seguridad y la
exposición de tal manera que no les
puede explicar lo tendrían que
experimentar
pero realmente vale muchísimo la pena
algunas de las herramientas para
finalizar que me han ayudado mucho a mí
son 68 cosas que les puedo decir a
grandes rasgos porque podría echar de
aquí dos horas platicándoles una de las
primeras cosas que yo sentí que me lleva
muchísimo hacer conciencia de mí y de
cómo me voy cotizada es la incomodidad
la incomodidad es el perfecto foco rojo
para salir corriendo para el otro lado
estoy segura que ustedes pueden evocar
si les cuesta trabajo pues va a instalar
la adolescencia y hay muchísimas pero
hoy en día una situación en la que están
comprometidos una situación donde los
tan cómodos donde por algo no se sienten
a gusto deja de hacerlo hoy eso lo va a
llenar todas y existencial de por cosas
que te neutral de verdad que van de
acuerdo con tus valores con tus
principios con quien tú eres
otra de las cosas que es interesante es
los juicios que emitimos
tienes que observar los juicios que
emite es porque te delatas
tengo una vida aquí o por la vida hay
que viajar más largo
alguna de acá y es que las nalgas de
esta mujer es sí y quién quiere quedar a
más de alguno de todo el grupo pues ella
hay que fijarse bien en cómo juzga uno
porque eso eso es pues sólo habla de
nosotros no realmente otra de las cosas
que yo les invito a hacer es es
acostumbrarse a crear una vida
apasionante para ustedes mismos o sea
algo que sea de ti por ti para ti a
verte tus gustos sino cuando llegó la
hora de darte tus gustos de estar tú en
la primera lugar de tus expresiones de
amor arreglar todos estos detalles de tu
vida quién no le ha pasado a mí en una
época llegaba de la televisión diario a
mi casa y en la etapa del control no
salía y se me caí es' me caen las pilas
ya no puedo sos diario y vive así lo
saco meses con la gente que se
acostumbra a bañarse al principio con
tanto agua caliente y luego frías al
física la circulación con tal de no ver
nada en el boiler
hay que ser la nuestra vida in the cable
tienes que ver por ti en primer lugar
hacer de tu vida la mejor vida que
puedas tener tienes que ser valiente
atreverte hacer tu honrar la persona que
eres lo que sientes lo que te hace fluir
ser tu otra cosa muy importante es
ubicar tus pensamientos
la mente es naturalmente obsesiva y
reproduce todo lo que pensamos desde la
cuenta que piensas tienes que cambiar
todos tus pensamientos a positivo si te
va a cambiar la vida tú le vas a dar lo
confirme
y creo que es otra de las cosas que es
importante es
no sé consciente de quién eres cómo te
has ido tapando de todo lo que ha
reprimido lo que lo que se reprime se
estanca en lo que se está en carpeta
y estamos por la vida yéndonos a meditar
al retiro de silencio o la ayahuasca
está tan famosa la raíz que tú te pones
hasta el gorro con tal de poder conectar
contigo o de fluir porque nos hemos
tapado tanto todavía nos hemos enterado
enfermedad que pusieras es difícil
llegarle dejar de reprimir cosas
atrévete a ser tú y no vas a necesitar
recurrir a todas estas cosas la
desesperación
yo creo que el que no arriesga no gana
los retos a que dejen lo que quieren ser
y dedicarse a ver quiénes son ya través
de hacer ustedes mismos porque la vida
es de los valientes
y lo que pasa si te atreves a hacer tú
es mucho menos grave de lo que te estás
imaginando muchas gracias
este tipo